สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงแล้วก็
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนนะคะโอเคเดี๋ยวเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะ
คะ
ครับวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับวันพุธ
ครับวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3 ครับเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคมครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูนิก
ตอนนี้นะครับเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
830 นโอ 8 ตเช้านะครับค่ะใช่แล้วเมือง
ที่ครูหญิงอยู่ครับเวลากี่โมงเมืองที่ครู
หญิงอยู่ตอนนี้ก็
930 นค่ะอ้าโอเคเนาะเร็วกว่าเหมือนกัน
ใช่ก็ 9:30 นเนาะอือครับ
โอเค
เอ่อครูหญิงกินข้าวหรือยังครูหญิงยังไม่
ได้กินข้าวเลยค่ะครูนิกอะไรคะกินข้าวหรือ
ยังครูนิครูนิกอ่ะยังไม่ได้
กินใช่ก็หิมหิวหิวคือตอนแรกนะคุณนิกอ่ะ
ตื่นนอนมาแล้วก็ยังไม่หิวแล้วแฟนคุณนิกะ
เขาทำกับข้าวเาก็ถามว่าทำกับข้าวให้มย
เพราะว่าเขาออกไปข้างนอกตอนเช้าวันนี้คุณ
บอกไม่ไม่ต้องทำเพราะว่าไม่หิวพอพูดหลัง
จากนั้นน่ะ 5 นาทีหิวหิวแต่เราก็แบบเออ
เราบอกแฟนไปแล้วว่าเราไม่หิวเออไม่เป็นไร
เดี๋ยวทำกับข้าวกินเองตอนเช้ากำลังคิดว่า
อาจจะต้มมาม่ากินเอก็ดีนะคะคุณนิยิ่งถ้า
แบบว่าอากาศเนาะฝนตกเอยอากาศเย็นๆเต้ม
มาม่าเนี่ยอร่อยมากๆนะคะใช่ๆมาม่ากับไข่
ต้มอือแต่แฟนคุณนิเาก็จะเค้าเเก็มองนิด
นึงนะว่าเวลาคุณนิกินอะไรที่มันที่เขาไม่
ชินน่ะเหมือนกับข้าวไข่เจียวหรือมาม่าตอน
เช้าเามองว่ามันเป็นอาหารที่มันไม่ต้อง
กินตอนเช้าสิ
อือทำไมมากินใช่ก็
แมันเป็นของตอนเที่ยงมากกว่าอืแต่คนไทย
เราเรากินได้ตลอดนะคะแล้วแบบมาม่าเนี่ย
มันเป็นอะไรที่กินง่ายๆกินเร็วๆถ้าเรามี
เวลา
น้อยแล้วหิวอ่ะอืก็กินมาม่าได้เพราะว่า
เหมือนเคยได้ยินว่าแบบเครื่องบินใช่มั้ย
คะแบบแอร์เอเชียอย่างเงี้ยของไทยนะยังมี
มาม่าขายบนเครื่องบินเลยอ่ะ
ใช่ๆก็เป็นมาก็เป็นแบบถ้วยมันก็เป็นอะไร
ที่ง่ายแล้วไว
อืใช่แต่คุณนิก็คิดคิดนะครับว่าพวกอาหาร
แบบนี้เนี่ยอย่างมาม่าเนี่ยมันง่ายแล้วก็
มันเอาไปไหนมาไหนได้ง่ายบนเครื่องบินก็มี
ขายคุณนิกจำไม่ผิด
ว่าไม่รู้ว่าครูครูหญิงเคยขึ้นรถทัวร์
บ่อยมโอเมื่อก่อนขึ้นบ่อยมากค่ะคือคุณนิ
ก็คิดว่ารถทัวร์เนี่ยก็มีเหมือนกันอืแต่
ผู้หญิงไม่เคยขึ้นรถทัวร์แบบไกลอ่ะค่ะครู
นิกครับแค่คิดว่าถ้านั่งรถทัวร์แบบนานที่
สุดน่าจะไปพัทยาไม่รู้กี่ชั่วโมงกรุงเทพ
พัทยาแค่นั้นแต่ปกตินั่งรถทัวร์จาก
กรุงเทพฯกลับบ้านมันประมาณ 2 ช่วโมงแล้ว
กันอ่ะแค่นั้นเองมันไม่มีอะไรขายเลยอ่ะ
ค่ะรถทัวร์กรุงเทพฯชลบุรีอ่ะออคือของครู
นิกเนี่ยเวลานั่งรถทัวร์เนี่ยครูนิกจะ
นั่งรถทัวร์ยาวๆอืเพราะว่าบ้านอย่างเวลา
ไปหาคุณแม่ครับที่อยู่ภาคเหนือบางทีคุณ
นิกอ่ะขี้เกียจขึ้นเครื่องบินเพราะว่ารถ
ทัวร์เวลาถ้านั่งนานๆแบบ 7 ชั่วโมง 10
ชมงมันก็จะเป็นรถทัวร์ตอนกลางคืนเราก็นอน
บนรถทัวร์ได้แล้วตื่นเช้าก็ถึงพอดีใช่อื
คือจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยเหตุผลที่นั่งรถทัวร์
เพราะว่าถ้านั่งเครื่องบินเนี่ยหาคนไปรับ
ที่สนามบินยากเพราะว่าของคครูนิกเนี่ยมัน
จะต้องนั่งไปลงที่เชียงใหม่แล้วจากบ้าน
แม่ของครูนิกเนี่ยไปเชียงใหม่ต้องขับรถ 1
ชมครึ่งอู้หูใช่ใช่ครับทีนี้เนี่ยรถทัวร์
เนี่ยก็จอดหน้าบ้านเลยเออก็สะดวกกว่านะ
แบบไม่ต้องคิดเออใช่ๆๆค่ะคือจริงๆอ่ะ
สะดวกแม่ครูนิกนะไม่ได้สะดวกคูณนิจริงๆก็
สะดวกคครูนิกเหมือนกันคูณนิกก็ไม่ซีเรียส
แต่ก็คือเขาก็บอกว่านั่งรถทัวร์ดีกว่าจะ
ได้ไม่ต้องเช้าไปรับมันขับรถนานคือเราแค่
คิดว่าจากสนามบินไปที่บ้านของแม่เนี่ย 1
ชมครึ่งแต่เขาต้องขับมาขับกลับ 3 ชมงอื
ใช่เขาก็คงแบบเออเหนื่อยกว่าเก็เลยรู้สึก
ว่าเอองั้นลูกนั่งรถทัวร์เหอะเอใช่ๆๆก็
แล้วก็อีกครั้งนึงที่เคยนั่งก็คือจริงๆก็
ไม่ได้ก็นั่งหลายครั้งครับเคยนั่งจาก
กรุงเทพฯไปภูเก็ต
อื้อหือกี่ชั่วโมงคะ
ชมง 12 ชมงใช่เป็นยังไงอ่ะครุนี้ิคือครู
หญิงเคยได้ยินนะอันนี้เคยได้ยินแบบพี่คน
อื่นเเล่าว่าการนั่งรถทัวร์ลงภาคใต้คือคน
ขับรถทัวร์ต้องเก่งมาก
ๆใช่เพราะว่าคือจริงๆเนี่ยรถทัวร์เดี๋ยว
ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนเคยเห็นรถทัวร์มยเดี๋ยว
จะให้ดูรูปภาพก่อนใช่คือรถทัวร์ในคือคน
ไทยพูดรถทัวร์เนี่ยก็คือรถที่วิ่งครับ
ระหว่างจังหวัดอ่าเหมือนแบบอ่ากรุงเทพฯ
ชลบุรีกรุงเทพเชียงใหม่อย่างเงี้ยค่ะ
เนี่ยรถทัวร์ใช่เราคือมันก็เป็นรถบัสคัน
ใหญ่นะอืใช่ค่ะอันนี้เนี่ยมัน 2 ชั้นเหรอ
คะใช่ 2 ชั้นครับอืออืก็ครูนิกเนี่คิดว่า
มันก็รถทัวเนี่ยมันจะมี 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้นแต่
มันก็จะอยู่ชั้นสูงๆอันนี้แหละข้างล่าง
ที่เป็นชั้นล่างเนี่ยมันก็จะมีที่นั่งไม่
เยอะค่ะครับใช่แต่ส่วนใหญ่ก็จะอยู่ข้างบน
คุณนี้ิก็คิดเหมือนกันนะว่าไม่รู้ทำไมรถ
รถเมล์ที่ไทยเนี่ยมันจะต้องเหมือนขึ้น
บันไดขึ้นไปแล้วก็ไปหาที่นั่งทำไมมันไม่
มีเหมือนกับเป็นแบบปกติที่ว่าไม่ต้องขึ้น
บันได 2-3 ขั้นเออเหมือนเดินขึ้นอย่างงี้
เลยใช่มั้ยคะออเพราะว่าผู้หญิงไม่เคยไม่
เคยนั่งรถทัวร์ 2 ชั้นเลยอ่ะอหยถึงที่ไทย
นะที่ไทยอ่ะไม่เคยนั่งแต่จริงๆอ่ะถ้าครู
นิกเลือกอ่ะครูนิกอ่ะคือถ้าเป็น 1 ชั้น 2
ชั้นครูนิกก็จะนั่งข้างบนอยู่ดีอใช่เพราะ
คุณนิแค่คิดว่าชั้นล่างอ่ะมันอยู่ใกล้กับ
คนขับคนขับรถทัวร์แล้วก็มันอยู่ใกล้ห้อง
น้ำ
อืมันก็จะมีกลิ่นนิดหน่อยกลิ่นคือกลิ่น
ที่ไม่อยากได้กลิ่นใช่ต้องบอกก่อนว่าห้อง
น้ำที่รถทัวร์ในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันไม่ได้
สะอาดหรือดูดูโอเคเหมือนอย่างรถทัวร์ต่าง
ประเทศที่ครูนิเคยเห็นนะใช่ใช่ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าอย่างอย่างของครูหญิงเอออย่างของครู
หญิงอ่ะอ่ามันวิ่งใกล้ๆใช่มั้ยมันจะเป็น
รถทัวร์ชั้นเดียวอ่ะค่ะครูนิกแล้วก็ห้อง
น้ำมันจะอยู่ข้างหลังคือเคย 1 ครั้งที่
แบบว่าเรารีบอ่ะแล้วเราได้นั่งข้างหลัง
ที่ใกล้ห้องน้ำอ่ะครับคือมีกลิ่นจริงๆนะ
คะออใช่มันเหมือนเออแล้วเราแบบแล้วมัน
เป็นแอร์เนาะรถทัวร์มันไม่มีหน้าต่างที่
เปิดแล้วก็ให้ลมเข้าได้อ่ะค่ะแต่ยังโชคดี
ว่าเรานั่งไม่ได้ไกลมากประมาณ 2 ชั่วโมง
ครับใช่ก็เท่าที่ครูนิกเคยเห็นเนี่ยเพราะ
ว่าครูนิกจะนั่งรถทัวร์แบบยาวๆมันก็จะมี
ให้เลือก 2 ชั้นแต่ถ้าสั้นๆก็อาจจะมีก็
อาจจะเป็นชั้นเดียวนั่นแหละครับแต่แค่ว่า
ครูนิกไม่ค่อยได้เห็นบ่อยแล้วก็มันจะมี
ถ้าเป็นรถทัวร์แบบยาวๆที่กรุงเทพฯ
เชียงใหม่กรุงเทพภูเก็ตเา้าก็จะมีตัว
เลือกให้นะว่าสมมุติบริษัทนี้เค้าก็จะมี
เลือกให้ว่าจะเอาเป็นชั้น 1 หรือ First
CL โอเหมือนเครื่องบินอย่างเงี้ยเหรอใช่
อันเนี้ยคือที่ครูนิกเห็นบ่อยเนี่ยก็คือ
จะเป็นรถทัวร์ที่ไปทางภาคเหนือค่ะอออ้
เดี๋ยวออาจจะพอนั่งไกลใช่อาจจะพอนั่งไกล
แต่เมื่อกี้เพิ่งนึกได้ว่าเราพูดถึงขับรถ
ทัวร์ลงทางภาคใต้ใช่มั้ยใช่ๆๆคือว่าภาค
ใต้เนี่ยที่เขาบอกว่าคนขับรถต้องเก่งมากๆ
เพราะว่าถนนที่ลงภาคใต้เนี่ยมันอันตราย
เพราะว่าคือเขาบอกว่ามันเป็นถนนที่มันยาว
ตลอดแล้วบางทีคนที่ขับเนี่ยเพราะมันคิด
ว่ามันยาวตลอดมันไม่ได้มีมันไม่ได้มี
เหมือนกับจุดให้จอดหรือว่าเข้าไปในตัว
เมืองของจังหวัดที่ขับผ่านมันก็จะทำให้
บางคนเนี่ยพอขับเร็วไปแล้วมันก็เร็วขึ้น
เรื่อยๆไม่รู้ตัวอือันตรายแล้วก็ถนน
เหมือนกับบางที่เนี่ยมันถนนยังไม่ดีค่ะ
ครับใช่คือเค้าบอกว่าถ้าขับลงมาเนี่ย
เหมือนกับพอพ้นประจวบคีรีขันธ์นะใช่ก็จะ
เริ่มอันตรายละอืๆๆพอเริ่มเข้าภาคใต้จริง
ๆและใช่่ๆเพราะแต่จริงๆเนี่ยจังหวัด
ประจวบเนี่ยที่คนไทยจะเรียกสั้นๆหรือว่า
ประจวบเป็นจังหวะที่ยาวมากูหญิงกำลังจะ
พูดเลยค่ะครูนิกคือครุหญิงอ่ะเคยนั่งคือ
หัวหินน่ะนะนักเรียนน่ะน่าจะรู้จักก็คือ
หัวหินอืเคยนั่งรถตู้แล้วกันเนาะมันไม่
ใช่รถทัวร์แต่ว่ามันก็คล้ายๆกันน่ะค่ะ
แล้วแบบเราเราไม่ได้ไปหัวหินน่ะเรารู้สึก
แบบนี่ฉันนั่งข้ามอีกจังหวัดนือเปล่าอ่ะ
ยังไม่ถึงอีกหรอคือมีความรู้สึกว่าแบบ
แล้วคิดถึงคนที่จะต้องนั่งข้ามไปอีก
จังหวัดนึงที่ไม่ได้ไปประจวบอ่ะครับคงจะ
รู้สึกไกลมากโหอันนี้อะไรคะครูนิกในรูป
เนี่ยอันอันเนี้ยนะคือรถทัวร์ของคุณนิกจำ
ไม่ได้ว่าแต่เป็นรถทัวร์ที่ขับจาก
กรุงเทพฯไปเชียงใหม่ค่ะใช่คืออันเนี้ยจำ
ไม่ได้ว่าชื่อของบริษัทอะไรบริษัทรถถั่ว
ถ้าจำไม่ผิดน่าจะเวียงพิงหรือเปล่าใช่อื
น่าจะใช่เวียงพิงครับมันมีชื่อตรงนี้เป็น
เวียงพิงบัสครับอันเนี้ยครับเป็นรถทัวร์
ชั้น 1 อืครับมันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้เลยถ้า
ชั้น 1 นี่ครูนิกรู้มั้ยคะว่ามันราคา
ประมาณเท่าไหร่อ่ะคือครูนิกนะไม่เคยนั่ง
ของบริษัทนี้เพราะว่าเอ่อบริษัทนี้เนี่ย
เนี่ยคือสมบัติทัวร์ใช่สมบัติทัวร์แล้ว
เป็นเ CL อันนี้เนี่ยเขาจะเรียกว่าเป็น
เวียงพิงบัสอราคาน่าจะอยู่ประมาณ 1,000
บาทอ้อ้ก็โอเคนะก็โอเคเพราะว่าถ้ารถทัวร์
เนี่ยอย่างอันนี้ถ้าถ้าเท่าที่ครูนิกรู้
นะจากกรุงเทพฯไปเชียงใหม่เนี่ยรถทัวร์
ราคาจะอยู่ประมาณ
600 บาทถึง 1,000 บาทอืแล้วถ้าเป็นแบบ
ชั้น 1 หรือว่าแบบเ่อ first  class แบบ
เนี้ยแล้ว 1,000 บาทก็ไม่แย่นะก็ไม่แย่
ใช่สำหับเออการนั่งนานๆแล้วขาเอยอ่ะนอน
สบายใช่มีที่ชาร์จแบตให้มีทีวีให้ด้วยเอ
แบบนั้นเออสำหรับคุณนิคูนี้ก็คิดว่ามัน
โอเคนะแล้วมันไม่ต้องนั่งคั่งใครด้วย
เพราะมันเป็นที่นั่งแบบ 1 ที่แล้วก็เป็น
ทางเดินแล้วก็ 1 ที่ค่ะแล้วก็ที่นั่งก็
ค่อนข้างกว้างใช่มั้ยคะนั่งสบายครับคือ
ที่นั่งมันก็ใหญ่เหมือนกับเรานั่งเครื่อง
บินชั้น Business อ่ะชั้นธุรกิจเลยอืใช่
อืออันนี้ก็จะเป็นเพว่าแบบสมบัติทัวร์อื
ออแล้วถ้าลงใต้เนี่ยมีมั้ยคะแบบที่นั่ง
แบบเป็นเฟเอ่อชั้น 1 แบบนี้ลงใต้เนี่ยคุณ
คุนิกอ่ะยังไม่เคยเห็นคือที่คครูนิกนั่ง
จากกรุงเทพฯลงภูเก็ตเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นของ
บขสค่ะถ้าบขสชั้น 1 เนี่ยคือเดี๋ยวนะบขส
เขาจะเรียกว่าบขสตอง 9 ครับก็คือพ.ศ 9999
อันแบบเนี้ยครูนิกยังไม่เคยนั่งคือที่ครู
นิกนั่งเนี่ยจะเป็นอันนี้โอก็ดูดีนะคะครู
นี้มันก็มันก็ดีครับเพราะว่ามันจะเลือก
ได้ว่าจะนั่งแบบคนเดียวหรือ 2 คนอืแล้วก็
แบบเหมือนดูตรงนี้ก็มีที่แบบให้เหมือน
ปรับโอ้อันนี้คงไม่ใช่หมุนงี้นะน่าจะกดนะ
คะแล้วก็ปรับวางขาได้ใช่ๆแล้วมันก็จริงๆ
มันก็เบาะที่นั่งอ่ะครับมันก็เอนได้เยอะ
นะอืมันก็สบายเหมือนกันใช่ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็
คือคุณหญิงก็เคยคือเคยนั่งรถทัวร์ที่
อเมริกาไงคะแล้วรู้สึกว่าเค้าไม่ได้ให้
เราเลือกที่นั่งได้อ่ะอืเหมือนถ้าเราจะ
เลือกว่าเราอยากนั่งที่นั่งเบอร์อะไรเรา
ต้องจ่ายเงิน
เพิ่มอ๋ออันหญิงอันนี้อันนี้อันนี้ไม่รู้
ว่าเป็นเป็นเฉพาะบริษัทที่ครูหญิงเคยนั่ง
หรือเปล่านะคะไม่รู้ว่าบริษัทอื่นๆเนี่ย
มีมั้ยแต่ถ้าที่ไทยอ่ะเวลาเราซื้อตั๋วรถ
ทัวร์เราเลือกได้เลยว่าเราอยากนั่งเบอร์
อะไรครับอือเดี๋ยวของของที่ครูหญิงนั่ง
เนี่ยบริษัทอะไรครับเอ่อ megabus ค่ะอ๋อ
megabus  megabus จริงๆไม่รู้จักน่าจะ
เป็นน่าจะเป็นของรัฐที่ครูหญิงอยู่คือที่
ครูนิกได้ยินเนี่ยถ้าที่เขาใช้กันเยอะๆ
มันก็จะมีเกย House เกย House มันก็จะ
เหมือนกับที่เห็นเนี่ยมันก็จะมีไปตามรัฐ
ต่างๆมีในชิคาโก้ในรัฐใหญ่ๆมันก็จะมีเฮา
แต่เฮาคูนิจำไม่ได้ว่าเสียเงินมยถ้าต้อง
เลือกถ้าต้องเลือกที่นั่งอือเพราะว่าอัน
นี้ครูหญิงนั่ง
แบบ 2 ชมงนะประมาณ 2
ชมงแบบลงอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแบบมันก็จะมีแบบจาก
ที่นี้แล้วก็แบบไปวอชิงตันดีซีอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะไปฟิลาเดลเฟียไปบอสตันก็มีนะอ่าแล้วก็
แบบนั่งประมาณ 2 ชมงแต่ว่าเค้าไม่อย่าง
ครูหญิงเนี่ยเลือกที่นั่งข้างหน้าที่แบบ
ข้างบนน่ะค่ะแล้วก็ข้างหน้าติดกระจกเยก็
คือเราจ่ายเพิ่มประมาณอืมน่าจะ 6  6
เหรียญหรือเปล่าไม่แน่ใจต่อ 1 ที่อย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะแต่ว่าก็ไม่เห็นว่าคนอื่นก็คือ
ขึ้นมาปุ๊บเรานั่งตรงไหนก็ได้ไงเราก็เลย
แบบอ๋อรถทัวร์ที่นี่เ้าไม่ต้องเลือกที่
นั่งหรอเพราะว่าที่ไทยเนี่ยมันจะจองมาเลย
อ่ะค่ะเวลาเราซื้อตั๋วเงี้ยค่ะเราไม่ต้อง
บอกก็ได้อ่าแต่คนที่ขายตั๋วเนี่ยเขาจะให้
ตั๋วมาใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็จะบอกเราว่าที่นั่ง
ของเราเนี่ยแถวอะไรแถว 1  2  3  a  b  c
d อย่างเงี้ยแบบเอออันนี้คือที่ไทยจะ
เป็นแบบนี้หมดเลยไงคะก็เลยใชใช่จริงๆที่
ไทยจะเป็นแบบนั้นก็ต่างประเทศเนี่ยครูนิ
เคยเห็นว่าในในยุโรปเนี่ยเา้าก็จะให้
เลือกได้ว่าจะจองที่นั่งหรือไม่จองแล้วอ
คือจริงๆเนี่ยที่นั่งเนี่ยเราเค้าไม่ได้
บังคับว่าเราต้องเลือกเพราะว่าขึ้นรถไป
นั่งตรงไหนก็ได้ใช่คือมันก็จะมีป้ายเท่า
ที่ครูนิกเคยเห็นนะหรือเคยใช้รถทัวร์รถ
บัสต่างในยุโรปเนี่ยเขาก็จะมีคำเหมือนกับ
เขียนเอาไว้ว่าจองอยู่ข้างบนแล้วเราก็จะ
ดูว่าออโอเคถ้าเราจองที่นั่งนี้มันจะมี
ป้ายคำว่าจองให้จะไม่ได้บอกว่าของใครแต่
แค่บอกว่าจองคนที่เขาขึ้นมาแล้วเห็นว่า
ที่นั่งนี้มีป้ายจองเขาก็จะไม่นั่งอืนั่น
แหละครูหญิงก็เลยไม่เข้าใจที่อเมริกาว่า
อย่างครูหญิงตอนตอนขาไปใช่ไหมคะหรือว่าขา
กลับอ่ะก็จองนั่นแหละจองที่นั่งข้างหน้า
ข้างบนอ่าที่อยู่ใกล้กับอะไรนะกระจกอ่ะ
ค่ะอ่าแล้วพอเราขึ้นมาปุ๊บเราก็เห็นอ้า
มันก็ไม่มีป้ายเขียนเอาไว้ว่าจองแล้วถ้า
สมมุติว่าครูนิกเดินขึ้นมาแล้วคือเราอยาก
นั่งตรงไหนก็ได้ใช่ไหมมแล้วเราก็ไม่รู้
ว่าตรงไหนที่มีคนจองอืแล้วถ้าสมมุติครู
นิกมานั่งเก้าอี้ที่ผู้หญิงจองพอครูหญิง
ขึ้นมาครู้หญิงก็ต้องบอกว่าเอ่อขอโทษนะ
ฉันจองครับคุนี้นี้ก็ต้องลุกขึ้นแล้วก็หา
ที่นั่งใหม่ผู้หญิงก็เลยแบบเอ้าแล้วจะรู้
ได้ยังไงอ่ะว่าเก้าอี้ตัวไหนหรือที่นั่ง
ตัวไหนมีคนจองแล้วครับใช่อันนีู้หญิงไม่
เข้าใจเหมือนกันคืออันนั้นน่ะครูหญิงคือ
ครูนิกเคยเจอเหมือนกันว่ามีคนนั่งที่ครู
นิกจองค่ะเค้าก็คือมันก็จะรู้สึกแปลกๆนิด
นึงว่าทำไมเราต้องเป็นคนคุยเองว่าเออ
เนี่ยที่นั่งชนะไปนั่งที่อื่นเพราะว่ามัน
ก็มีหลายคนที่เขาไม่ได้จองที่นั่งแล้วเา
นั่งแบบนั้นเพราะเขาไม่คิดว่ามันจะมีคน
จองที่นั่งแล้วต้องนั่งตรงนั้นจริงๆใช่
มันก็จะรู้สึกแปลกๆว่าทำไมเราต้องไป
คุยใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าที่ไทยเนี่ยถ้าซื้อคิด
ว่ารถทัวร์ขึ้นเหนือหรือว่ารถทัวร์ลงใต้
รถทัวร์ทุกที่ในไทยเนี่ยเราจะได้ที่นั่ง
มาเลยเหมือนเครื่องบินใช่มั้ยคะว่าเราได้
นั่งตรงไหนแล้วเราก็บอกได้นะคะถ้าอยาก
นั่งใกล้กับ
หน้าต่างหรือว่ากระจกแบบดูวิวอย่างเงี้ย
แถวหนแถวหน้าเลยอย่างเงี้ยก็ถ้าเา้ายัง
ไม่เต็มเราบอกได้อืในู้แถวบ้านู่หญิงอ่ะ
บอกได้ค่ะอืก็ใช่เออก็ดีนะแล้วก็อะไรนะ
เกี่ยวกับรถทัวร์อออีกอย่างนึงรถโทที่ไทย
เนี่ยถ้านั่งยาวๆไกลๆเ้าจะต้องมีเจะเรียก
ว่าหยุดกินข้าวด้วยใช่มั้ยเคยได้ยิน
เหมือนกันกินข้าวต้มส่วนใหญ่ก็ตกลางคืน
อ่ะเหรอคะโอโหตอนกลางคืนใช่ครับถ้าจริงๆ
เขาคก็จะจอดเหมือนกับว่าถ้ามันถ้าจำไม่
ผิดนะครับประมาณถ้า 8 ชมงขึ้นไปเจะต้อง
จอดให้พักกินข้าวประมาณครึ่งชั่วมงคือ
จริงๆเค้าก็จะจอดเพื่อเปลี่ยนคนขับด้วย
ค่ะอ๋อเพราะว่าขับนานเนาะมันเหนื่อยใช่
มันเหนื่อยแล้วก็ก็จะเป็นจุดจุดจอดกิน
ข้าวมันก็จะเป็นเหมือนกับโรงอาหารนั่น
แหละครับใช่แต่ส่วนใหญ่เค้าก็จะมันก็จะมี
ให้เลือกว่าเค้าจะให้ได้เป็นคูปองมาเป็น
บัตรว่าโอเคเอาไปให้กับร้านขายข้าวเค้าก็
จะให้ข้าวมาเพราะเขจะรู้ว่าอ๋อมาจากรถ
ทัวร์คันนี้คันนี้อ๋อก็คือเราไม่ต้องจ่าย
เงินเพิ่มใช่มั้ยคะอันนี้รวมอยู่ในราคา
ตั๋วแล้วใช่่อแต่อาหารมันก็จะไม่ได้ดีมาก
นะครูหญิงคือถ้าเราอยากจะกินอาหารที่ดี
กว่านี้เค้าก็จะมีขายแยกออกมาเราก็ซื้อใน
ร้านรองอาหารตรงนั้นเลย
อ๋อก็คือถ้าอยากกินแบบอร่อยดีๆก็จ่ายเงิน
เพิ่มก็เนี่ยอันเนี้ยคือที่ครูนิเคยกิน
มันก็จะเป็นแบบอย่างเงี้ยโหไช
โป๊ข้าว
ต้มหรือแบบเล็กๆแบบเนี้ย
ครับน่ารักเออเหมือนอาหารเด็กอือถ้าเรา
ไม่คิดมากก็กินๆไปแล้วก็กลับไปนอนนอนต่อ
นะคะใช่แต่ก็มีคนที่ไม่กินเา้าก็บอกว่า
ถ้าไม่กินก็เอาคูปองนั้นไปแลกซื้อไปแลก
เอาเครื่องดื่มได้ที่เป็นน้ำเปล่าน้ำ
ผลไม้หรือโค้กเปปซี่ก็ได้ค่ะ
อืก็อันนี้ก็ดีนะคะเป็นประสบการณ์เนาะ
นั่งรถทัวร์แบบยาวๆนะคะใช่ก็ต้องแต่ก็
ต้องดูเวลาด้วยนะเพราะว่าบางทีพอเค้าจอด
เนี่ย
คือนักเรียนก็ไม่ต้องตกใจว่าเ้าจอดทำไม
ถึงแล้วหรอไม่ใช่จอดพักเพราะว่าข้ออีกข้อ
นึงคือถ้านั่งรถทัวร์เนี่ยเจะไม่พูดภาษา
อังกฤษเจะบอกโอเพัก 30 นาทีแต่ไม่บอกว่า
ยังไงแล้วมันก็มีคน
ที่เป็นไม่ใช่คนไทยอ่ะแล้วไม่รู้ว่าพูด
อะไรก็คิดว่าเออจอดรอไปเมื่อไหร่ก็ได้
แล้วก็มาดูอีกทีว่าอ้าวรถทัวร์ออกไปแล้ว
เค้าก็ไม่รอเราอย่างเงี้ยเหรอเค้าก็จริงๆ
เค้ารอมั้ยเค้าก็จะเช็คก่อนว่าขึ้นครบมย
แต่ถ้าเกิดว่าไม่ครบแล้วหาไม่เจอจริงๆ
เค้าก็ไปเลยนะ
โอใช่ออเพราะฉะนั้นก็นักเรียนก็เดาเอา
แล้วกันนะคะว่ารถทัวร์ก็น่าจะจอดประมาณ 30
นาทีใช่ให้เราคิดเอาไว้ 30 นาทีใช่ครับอื
ถ้าไม่อย่างงั้นหรือว่าถามเลยถามเ้าเลยก็
ได้ว่าอะไรใช่หรือถามได้ว่าเนี่ยกี่โมง
อยู่ที่นี่ถึงกี่โมงครับอืเนาะใช่เนาะก็
ครูก็มาเล่าให้ฟังนะคะเกี่ยวกับ
ประสบการณ์การนั่งรถทัวร์ที่ไทยเนาแต่ว่า
เดี๋ยวเรามาคิดว่าวีดีโอนี้ก็น่าจะหมด
เวลาแล้วนะคะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วดีโอ
หน้าได้ครับโอเคครับไว้เจอกันใหม่ครับครู
หญิงค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ครับ